they don't have to believe it my baby
[Music]
[Applause]
that's pure narcissism at work by the
way
[Applause]
you don't to hijack to hijack an event
like this that other people put time and
effort into and to use they there are
their civility of the crowd and the
civility of the organizers as an excuse
to blatantly yell out your ill informed
opinions is no way to conduct a civil
dialogue it's absolutely appalling the
people who do that should be embarrassed
[Music]
I guess I would also say that as
students and as faculty members you
shouldn't put up with it there's no way
that you should allow people who are
doing this to hijack your educational
opportunities and to bend and twist the
functions and the structures of the
university it's it's not a good thing
not in any way at all now you would say
that was a very disgraceful display
fundamentally so let's let's stick with
it why why do you think people are
afraid of free speech well you know
people develop an ideological view of
the world because they don't want to
think through things in real detail and
they're aided and abetted in that
endeavor by their pathological
professors who are feeding them what
would I say an oversimplified an
oversimplified radical view of the world
that in my estimation is fundamentally
based in in resentment not that there's
no reason for say a left-wing view of
the world and we can get to that later
it's it's easy virtue you know you can
stand up in front of 900 people with
your plaque art and your and your
screeching and you can you can declaimed
to the entire audience your fundamental
moral superiority you can tell everyone
at once that they're all beneath you and
you're standing for the right thing and
absolutely none of that is earned you
know like what they hit what the hell
was that there's it's come see really
man there's just it's just complete
misbehavior it's embarrassing and the
fact that people the people who do that
don't have enough sense to go hide their
head in shame it just tells you how
badly socialized they are and how
terribly educated they are and the thing
is the thing that's so awful is that
there are professors and educators who
promote that they say well that's how
you change the world it's like it is how
you change the world but it's certainly
not how you make it better
you make it worse clearly you know
there's no comfort in doubt and and
there's nothing about it this impressive
it's no it's no better in some sense
than a two-year-old having a tantrum on
the floor it's a it shows as far as I'm
concerned it approximate the same level
of psychosocial development so when the
fact that that this is happening
continually at universities is it's it
it truly makes me embarrassed to be
associated with the University and
I say that with great displeasure
because you know I've been working for
great universities for a very long time
and the university is an absolutely
remarkable institution you know it's
survived for a thousand years and and to
see it to see it brought down by my
people whose behavior would be out of
place at a four year olds birthday party
is is something something visible to
behold